لا يوجد حد للفوز بالسوق بأكمله حيث سيظهر رفيق الصفحة الرئيسية ، ولكن
تحول أحمق يسمى يناير ومظهره ومواده أصبح 0 بالنسبة لنا ، مجاعة جوتشي
اقلب الشركة رأسًا على عقب ورأسًا على عقب إلى الصورة الممزقة التي تقوم بها الآن
تم بناء روبي خلف الصخور ، وترسب لون لحم جينرو وإيان
اتخاذ قرار أقل من ذلك بقليل هو رفيق متوسط ​​الحجم في العديد من البلدان الأجنبية ، وهناك العديد من الإنجازات.
كان أحدهما زهرة
أوه ، قال ألف كلمة والتقط صورة تذكارية معهم.
أوه ، وأعضاء الحزب بناء على الخريطة الصينية الذين طلب منهم النوم
في وسط صناعة الورق في الشرق الأوسط ، نضع الإيقاع السينوبتيكي الخاص للتخزين الذي قدمه لنا رفاقنا.
تحسس ، وحفر ، وحرك ، وادعم بأمانة التركيز الذي يأمر به Seo-dong باستخدام الفأرة
مواهب يوليو لشراء دربي الخروج
من المؤلم ألا تفعل بنكًا واحدًا 3
[صفق]
أوه غونغ ورئيس مجلس الدولة ، هو الأفضل في جمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية
عقد الرفيق كيم سيونغ هون ، وهو بواب جديد ، مجلس الشعب الأعلى في 18 يناير.
لقاء أعضاء مجلس الوزراء المعينين حديثًا في الاجتماع متعدد الأطراف
التقطت صورة مجند معهم
يعطي علم الأورام الثقة في أن الرفيق كيم جونغ أون سوف يكون لديه إصبع حاد في تعيينه الجديد.
ما هي الصورة الخاصة التي التقطت معهم وهم يعبرون عن أنفسهم؟
جميع المشاركين عهدوا بهوية الأعمال الاقتصادية للبلاد وأعطوا ثقة كبيرة
مع رفع دور القاصر فيما يتعلق برفيق الادعاء الصالح الذي يتنازل مرارًا وتكرارًا ،
البناء الاقتصادي والهجرة يرجع حقًا إلى إطلاق سراح الحمر بحلول ليلة جيل شابي
لقد تعهدت بالولاء لتحقيق الكرة عالية الجودة في القمة.